this morning horse the new book by
pulitzer prize-winning author geraldine
brooks it's about a thoroughbred who at
one time sired more champions than any
other horse in history
no we're not talking about seabiscuit or
secretariat it's a horse named lexington
who raced before the civil war brook's
novel takes place during civil war times
and modern day it's a chance for her to
examine overlooked parts of our past
explore her love of ponies
and pay respect to her family
[Applause]
good morning to you too
that's a good sign when they do that
that means they're relaxed
geraldine brooks didn't start riding
horses until later in life
taking your first riding lesson at 54
maybe pottery on knitting would be a
better better choice
i'm impressed
as she told us when most people get a
red mustang
she got herself a black pony
her current horse is valentine joined
today by a happy neighbor the
thoroughbred here
is screaming hot wings that is a great
name for a horse
well she's only been riding for about 12
years
brooke's day's writing about horses go
back much further
after growing up in australia and
graduating from college with degrees in
political science and fine arts
she took a job in journalism and was
promptly thrown
on the horse racing beat
in those pre-internet days
rural bookmakers would pay out on the
results that were published in the
newspaper and if i made a mistake
i would be terminated and not just by
the newspaper
wow
so no pressure
an early experience with the impact of
journalism quite
brooks has now turned her history with
horses into an historical novel about a
famed horse named lexington who raced
before the civil war horse racing in the
1800s pre-civil war and post
it's as big as football is today i think
it might even be bigger
because in the 1850s this was still a
very agrarian society so everybody you
know had a horse or was one generation
away from having a horse or knew someone
who had a horse and everybody thought
that their horse could race
horse unfolds over three different time
periods in the 1800s when famous
paintings of lexington were made in the
1900s when one particularly famous
painting was rediscovered
and today when many of the issues that
surrounded lexington's life
are being re-examined
this is a story about a racehorse
that becomes about race
yes why did you decide to do that
i
learned as soon as i started researching
lexington
that this horse's incredible skill and
training and breeding
rested on the expertise of black
horsemen most of whom were enslaved or
formerly enslaved people in the
antebellum south
so you know it would have been
irresponsible to just foreground the
white characters the white owners even
though they're very interesting
characters i had to show
the contributions of these black
horsemen whether in her writing or in
her own life
race has never been far from brook's
mind
together with her husband on martha's
vineyard they raised sons nathaniel and
bizu who was adopted from ethiopia when
he was five
did you have to have the talk with your
son oh yeah oh yeah
and particularly
this island is a bit of an oasis in
terms of everybody knows everybody if
the cop pulls you over he's probably you
the cross coach you know so
when
when bizoo goes off island
we often remind him that you know not
everybody knows who you are so for many
just a summer getaway
this island has been brook's full-time
home for the past 17 years why martha's
vineyard well it goes back to when i was
11 years old and
i was a tragic
star trek fan
and i was a member of the leonard nimoy
fan club mr spock
live long and prosper i can say it in
the original vulcan if you like um
go and do it lash dora
and i had a i had a pen pal who was a
similar tragic trekkie
and she lived
in manhattan on martha's vineyard so she
would write to me
send me these beautiful postcards of the
sunsets down in that little fishing
village and i always thought what a
beautiful place i have to see that
someday before she was supposed to go
back to australia for good brooks
decided to visit the vineyard
encouraged by a friend who would become
her husband
both brooks and tony horwitz spent their
early years together as war
correspondents traveling the world
until both shifted into writing books
and eventually settled here
horwitz also a pulitzer prize winner
died suddenly three years ago at the age
of 60.
brooks has dedicated her latest novel
to his memory
you said for tony
it will be the past and will live there
together
well that's from a poem that i admire
called heaven
and that is
what i hope for is that
i'll see my brilliant funny wonderful
husband again when people think about
him today what do you want them to know
he was
an open-hearted curious historian
journalist he he used to describe
himself as a reporter on the history
beat he was very interested in how the
reverberations of the past still echo in
the present particularly to do with the
legacy of the civil war
um but he was also as funny as all get
out and that's what i miss the most is
the laughter every day
wow he is a man after my own heart she's
a woman
who is oh gosh such an incredible person
ben both wonderful writers thanks to
geraldine brooks for inviting us um to
go do this story the book horse is
eye-opening uh very i so encourage you
to check it out if you get a second um
but or or a little longer than a second
because there's a lot to mull over there
but and martha's vineyard as you know is
a beautiful
beautiful and they you live 17 years now
ever full time there it is
i'll be there this summer there you go